all right well going from what they call
fair and balanced to completely
unbalanced well you know what watch
yourself here's Pat Robertson when we
like things on Facebook if it's
something that goes against what is
written in the Bible such as pictures of
same-sex couples is that considered
condoning the behavior how do you
explain this to new Christians or youth
well I'm not one who switches on likes
and Facebook's it's hard to say but what
you're saying is yes I like this kind of
thing you've got a couple of same-sex
guys kissing you like that well that
makes me want to throw up but if you
think a you punch it to me I would punch
vomit not black you guys have that
searing pain going through your brain
how this man is even allowed he's alive
that I guess he funds his own network or
the people that are giving money to
Jesus they're putting up his television
program anyway he's punching vomit and
do a quick roll yeah when I believe when
somebody says I don't push likes on
Facebook that is your whatever they're
going to say what is the more offensive
part like his just language around faith
punching the the like button that's
really yeah I respect his beliefs and he
has every right to believe what he wants
to believe that's that's his right and I
think it's I probably never would have
seen that clip unless the you sent it to
a street I'm not I'm sorry so I did not
get that clip in my weekly email but um
you know take it for what it's worth I
think people are gonna look at that clip
and people make their own decisions and
be like okay he's just like he's like
crazy old man right that has no that
just can't see the world like that
people are different and then whatever
you know and vomit okay whatever
absolutely
my part of the problem here because
we're talking about this and it seems to
me that more people talk about Pat
Robertson the natural I don't know
anyone that watches the show but every
time he says something stupid it's on
every website I think it's actually good
to talk about because I think it's a
gauge of where the super super crazy
hardcore conservatives are even if there
are 140 because we've been seeing I
think what I've noticed is a lot of
really really conservative people
breaking down a little bit and and
accepting that the world is changing and
people are evolving and maybe what they
thought was true is not and so this is a
good temperature gauge of okay here's
another one is he is he breaking down to
see that you know people are people no
uncle Pat just go yet sit in the corner
you know this is Pat Roberts who of
course always blames gay people for
hurricanes and all that he just a few
weeks ago he said that you know someone
called in and said that their wife had
Alzheimer's and he said well you're
allowed to cheat on her now I mean he's
pretty intellectually inconsistent with
all that stuff
so which makes the point I think why
does God have such bad messengers you
know you mean God every time I think of
someone screaming about God it's either
Pat Robertson or you know Rick Santorum
or some idiot on the subway in New York
City screaming about Jesus why doesn't
you a better message supposed to answer
a question with a question but do you
really believe that these people are the
messengers of God I'm not sure they
count right so you want a card-carrying
yeah why doesn't if religion is a
legitimate thing and and all that if
we're gonna go that route for said for
the purposes of the conversation I mean
why doesn't God or whoever have better
representative that I'm preaching more
of the peace type things and except your
neighbor and all that I've said this my
whole life I think religion is a
personal thing and I'd like to keep it
personal you know I don't it's hard for
me to get behind somebody like him who
says sort of crazy things that I think a
lot of people probably even
conservatives can say okay that's a
little crazy that's a little much like
my my my wife has Alzheimer's so you're
allowed you have a pass you can go cheat
on her I'm like when is that ever okay
on even people that are atheist what in
the Bible did game you know game
I have a hard time when they when they
try to say things that the Bible didn't
actually quite say but they're
interpreting I'm like okay wait so
you're a man that's interpreting
something that I'm just supposed to
blindly follow when maybe if I read it I
would interpret it another way and a
great example that I'm not a New
Testament scholar by any stretch the
imagination or Old Testament when they
say that really because we brought you
on that they mentioned not not to eat
shrimp you know a thousand more times
than man not to lay with a man so you
know it's maybe lay off the crustaceans
too while you're preaching at that right
you know and doesn't it say really that
a man shall not lay with a man as he
would a woman but most gay men don't lay
with women like that so it's really not
it's all about loopholes